[Music]
From NBC News World Headquarters in New
York, this is NBC Nightly News with
Brian Williams. As his long manifesto
shows, the suspect in these killings
seemed to be heavily influenced by some
people in this country who write and
blog about the perceived threat from
Islam. And tonight, one of them, a man
named Robert Spencer, tells our national
investigative correspondent, Michael
Isachov he's being unfairly blamed for
any of the motivation behind this
tragedy.
In the aftermath of the Oslo mass
murder, investigators are focusing on
that 1500page manifesto in which accused
suspect Anders bearing Brevik vows
brutal and breathtaking operations in
order to stop the ongoing Islamic
colonization of Europe. Angry words
inspired, some analysts say, by heated
rhetoric from groups in the United
States, such as stop the Islamization of
America. Its co-founder, Robert Spencer,
is cited more than 50 times by Brevik.
Spencer has written that traditional
Islam contains violent and supremacist
elements. Brevik says he would be an
excellent choice for the Nobel Peace
Prize, but Spencer told NBC News today
he bears no responsibility for what
happened in Oslo. There's nothing in any
of my writings that is anything but a
defense of human rights, a defense of
the equality of rights before of all
people before the law. And so if
somebody gets from that that they should
kill, well then he's nuts. But some
analysts say words can be weapons
themselves. When you push the
demonization of populations, you often
end up with violence. And that may be
exactly what has happened, says Byrick.
The 2008 burning of a mosque in
Tennessee is evidence of what Byrick
says has been a spike in anti-Muslim
attacks, including arson and bombings in
Florida, Michigan, and Oregon. This
attack in Norway uh should be a wakeup
call for our country and for our
decision makers. Daryl Johnson tracked
extremist groups in the United States
for the Department of Homeland Security
and sees parallels with Breivik's
writings and we could have a similar
type of attack here and that's my
greatest fear is that we would have a
Timothy McVey type carry out a mass
shooting event. Homeland security
officials told us tonight they are
careful not to monitor political
protests but watch for domestic violent
extremist activity regardless of
ideology and so far they say they see no
evidence the problem is getting worse.
Michael Isikoff, NBC News,